how are you
hi good how are you doing i'm doing
excellent i really want to say sincerely
great job on season two um i finished it
uh it's so well done it's excellent
thank you oh my gosh
i'm so happy to hear that i've lost such
perspective because we've been so in the
trenches of it
so it
feels like a real
we really just threw it out came out of
the birth canal
uh you it's really excellent and i wish
i could talk specifically about episodes
nine and ten but i cannot so i know
we will move past that um
right uh so i'm curious for for fans
what what can you actually tease about
season two i hate asking the generic
thing but i think people want to know
season two is really kind of a
reflection of what it's you know we we
leave season one
with this sort of
seismic shift that takes place after the
two alex and bradley kind of dump that
that honesty jump in that you know the
news uh that broadcast that just sort of
shuts everything down and chaos ensues
and it's kind of like sifting through
the rubble of what what that the impact
of that and
everybody kind of has to step back and i
i know for my character you know takes a
break goes away
has to sort of sit with who she is and
what has she what she has done what she
allowed
who does she want to be
how can she be um
this was a lot of self-reflection and
identity
and also
then you know eventually
the devil you know you know she gets
seduced back to the world and then it's
i think she believes i think i'm a
different person i think i can still you
know show up
go back to the scene of the crime and
walk my talk this way and walk my walk
not so easy
so it's a real there's a lot of
wonderful twists and turns and you know
dealing with cancel culture
uh what does that look like you know we
really wanted to sort of address that in
terms of
you know go looking at the gray cause
it's just not so black and white
what happens to these people when they
just are canceled did they just is that
it where do they go
do they just live in the hamptons i mean
do they just you know go off to
is there a room for redemption
i think the answer is italy
or italy
wherever you know
wherever your spot may be
um you have some really great
emotionally charged scenes this season
uh and i'm curious i love asking actors
about how they get ready for something
like this and if you don't mind say you
know on a monday you're going to be
filming something that's really going to
be emotional how do you typically like
to prepare for like scenes like that can
you is it like days in advance you're
thinking about it is the night before
you're in your head i mean can you sort
of tell me about that i usually prep on
sunday for the week so i'll usually when
i work with this incredible woman nancy
banks who's uh who's been my
acting guru coach
um so we'll prep the week's work
we'll
you know kind of do but i don't ever
over prep because i find for me if i
over overly
think or overly rehearse a scene i lose
the spontaneity of it i just have to
know where i'm gonna go what what what
part of the will i have to kind of touch
at to in order to
portray the scene as truthfully as as as
i can
and it's not
easy
it's kind of
you know we did i did personally feel
like i crawled to the finish line of
this on an emotional level my i don't
think i've cried that much or been that
hysterical ever
uh
just even might you can even see in my
face it's just like the uh the tears
this the the everything has just fallen
from
all of it
i was going to say no you really did
such a great job this season you're
really cute
i'm so appreciative of that i it i was
saying but you know we you lose so much
perspective because we've been in it for
so long and in post-production and in
the editing and
it's just been um because i've said i
don't know maybe let's hope i think it's
okay i think we did it
but but thank you for that no you do
enjoyed it thank you so much for your
time my pleasure